with their towering height
and signature long necks
giraffes are some of the most iconic
creatures of africa
[Music]
giraffes are the tallest living land
animals
adult females can grow over 14 feet tall
and adult males can reach over 18 feet
baby giraffes called calves are born six
feet tall and may grow an additional
inch every day during their first week
this exceptional height allows giraffes
to eat leaves and buds from tree tops
unreachable by other animals
and to look out for predators and other
oncoming dangers
giraffes have exceptionally strong
hearts
their hearts are about two feet long and
weigh approximately 25 pounds
that's equal to about 50 human hearts
because of the great distance between a
giraffe's heart and its brain due to the
animal's long neck its heart has evolved
thick muscular walls
thanks to these powerful walls a
giraffe's blood pressure can be two
times higher than many other animals
this helps the giraffe's heart defy
gravity and push blood up its long neck
and into its brain
giraffes have the same number of neck
bones as humans
both humans and giraffes only have seven
bones in their necks
however
human neck bones are only half an inch
tall while giraffe bones are 10 inches
tall
this means giraffe necks can grow to be
about 6 feet long and weigh 600 pounds
male giraffes necks may also be used in
fights over females and to establish a
hierarchy within the herd
giraffes are capable of sleeping only
five minutes a
day giraffes can survive on 5 to 30
minutes of sleep each day which they get
through a series of one to two minute
naps they can even get their rest while
standing
[Music]
giraffes sleep this way out of necessity
they devote 16 to 20 hours each day to
eating which leaves little time for much
else
plus sleeping especially while lying
down exposes giraffes to predators
giraffe populations are vulnerable
found only in sub-saharan africa giraffe
populations plummeted up to about 40
percent between 1985 and 2015.
the animals are killed for their coats
or meat especially in poor countries
like south sudan
but they are also hunted specifically
for their tails which are considered
status symbols in some congolese
communities
no other creature on the planet is quite
like the giraffe
their height and long necks powerful
hearts and staccato sleeping style
easily make the creatures unique
[Music]
[Music]
you